[Musik]
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwelche großen neuen
Politiken geben wird, möglicherweise irgendetwas in der
Infrastruktur, aber meistens sind es die
Dinge, die nicht passieren werden. Wir werden
keine weiteren großen Steuersenkungen haben. Wir werden
keine großen Kürzungen bei Sozialprogrammen
haben  Es ist nicht klar, dass diese Dinge
sowieso passieren würden, aber diese Art von
Einfrierpolitik, die
schlimmer sein könnte, ein Haushaltsdefizit zu führen,
gibt der Wirtschaft einen gewissen Stimulus, auch
wenn es ziemlich nahe an der
Vollbeschäftigung ist, so dass ein Teil des jüngsten Wachstums das
ist  Aufgrund von Trumps Defiziten hätten
wir das natürlich
viel besser machen können, aber wir hätten es
unter Obama machen können, die Republikaner sagten, lass ihn das
tun, aber wir brauchen es jetzt nicht wirklich
und das Wichtigste, dass
Trump und nicht  exponieren sollte
einen großen Investitionsboom erzeugen, es
sollte das langfristige Wachstum in den USA
nicht nur um zwei Quartale
, sondern um zehn Jahre Wachstum
steigern, indem es ausländische Kapitalströme hereinbrachte und die
Investitionen ankurbelte  d Es gibt keine Anzeichen dafür, dass
irgendetwas davon passiert. Es sind alle
Steuersenkungen in Rückkäufe geflossen.
Ich denke, es sieht nicht gut aus. Lassen Sie
die Chance auf ein spiralförmiges Trittbrett, wir haben
bereits ein gutes Stück davon,
es gibt bereits einige echte Kosten  und und es
könnte noch viel mehr geben, denn das ist eine
persönliche Besessenheit von Trümpfen, Sie wollen
sicher sein, dass China irgendwie ein großartiges
Gebäude ist, nein, da könnten Sie sich vorstellen, dass
China in gewisser Weise eine schlechte Schwester ist und
über Dinge wie geistiges Eigentum wissen Sie
aber  Wenn
dies das Ziel war, dann würden Sie versuchen,
eine Koalition zusammenzustellen. Ich schätze, Sie
versuchen, einen Handelskrieg mit allen zu führen,
was Trump tut, also
glaube ich nicht, dass es eine wirkliche gibt,
es gibt keine kohärente wirtschaftliche Begründung
und und es wird auch von unschuldigen
Zuschauern eingeholt werden, ich meine
, obwohl China im Moment im Mittelpunkt zu stehen scheint,
würde ich nicht darauf zählen, dass Deutschland
aus der Schusslinie bleibt,
denke ich, dass Sie das wollen  Ich werde mich
zumindest vorerst zurückhalten und hoffen, dass diese
Trompete zu sehr damit beschäftigt ist, die
Chinesen oder die Kanadier oder irgendjemanden anzuschreien, und
nicht hinter dir her ist, aber ich denke,
du musst auch beides sagen, du musst sagen,
gut, weißt du  die USA  ist in der Tat keine
dominante wirtschaftliche Supermacht mehr und
es ist nicht wenig klar, dass
Deutschlands Interessen gedient sind, wenn man sich dabei
auf die Seite Amerikas stellt und auch die USA.
ist nicht in diesen oder anderen
Dingen ein rationaler Spieler und
jemand muss sich dafür einsetzen, dass es
Sinn macht. Ich denke, für das, was Sie
wissen sollten, haben wir gesagt, dass Ozlem
Urkel der effektive Anführer der
Freien ist  Welt an diesem Punkt und vielleicht verkaufe ich an diesem Punkt
einige Politiker des Welthandelssystems
[Musik]
Ja, ich meine nicht alles, aber diese
Hyperglobalisierung sind erweiterte
Wertschöpfungsketten, die sich in
den letzten 20 Jahren wirklich erweitert haben, die ziemlich
zerbrechlich sind, nicht  Nehmen Sie eine Menge
Protektionismus, um diese zu verdreifachen
[Musik]